wir wollen sie mit reinnehmen in putins
blutigen krieg um ihnen zu erklären wie
der stand der dinge ist wie der
frontverlauf ist und vielleicht auch
julian vorweg wie heldenhaft und mutig
sich immer noch die ukrainische armee
schlägt an diesem fünften kriegstag
tatsächlich einige hätten nicht damit
gerechnet dass das gerade kiew noch noch
nicht gefallen ist eigentlich noch nicht
damit gerechnet dass so viele russische
soldaten tatsächlich in diesem krieg
sterben aber ist wird zudem noch bei
manchen vorhergesagten blutbad und zwar
für beide seiten beide seiten des
blutbads sie haben heute morgen schon
viel von diesem drohnen schlägen gehört
und wir wollen ihnen ein so eine police
schlag genauer erklären was da passiert
wir sehen hier julian einen russischen
konvoi geparkt am straßenrand und dann
darüber eben die sich der ukrainischen
drohne die wir hier sehen nimm uns ein
bisschen mit rein was passiert jetzt
hier gleich und wer was läuft im
hintergrund ab ja also erst mal wie du
sagst dass es ein russischer kommen bei
und das ist ein nachschubkonvoi das
heißt wir haben hier ganz viele lkws und
jetzt sehen wir schon wie die drohnen
oder angreift ich hoffe ihr könnt es ein
paar mal zeigen damit wir das erklären
können erstmals zeugt das ganze von der
unglaublichen arroganz mit der putin da
reingeht wie diese militärfahrzeuge
angeordnet sind dass ich habe
verschiedene militärexperten gesprochen
auch die innen militär waren die sagen
so was gibt's doch gar nicht wer eines
davon explodiert und haben alle munition
an bord dann sind die alle dann brennen
die alle und insofern lässt man
eigentlich setzt man eigentlich jeweils
50 bis 100 meter platz zwischen diesen
verschiedenen trucks damit die wirklich
wenn einer getroffen wird von den
luftangriffen nicht alle getroffen
werden und wir sehen hier die sind
eigentlich dicht an dicht gepackt da ist
kaum eine lücke also man sieht auch dass
die eu keine wenn man das ganze video
sieht man hat eigentlich schon lange
streifen aber hier sind sie wird auch
noch nebeneinander drei nebeneinander
auf einer dünnen straße das ist wirklich
wahnsinn jetzt weitere reihe dritter
ganz genau und wir sehen dann dass die
ukrainische drohne dort kommt könnte es
ja vielleicht noch mal ansehen hierbei
handelt es sich um eine bayraktar drohne
aus türkischer produktion
lieber auch schon über syrien sehr aktiv
die war im armenien aserbaidschan krieg
sehr aktiv und wir sehen jetzt gleich
was hier in alle richtung geht das sind
also raketen das ist munition die hier
explodiert sondern barak patrone die hat
ja die also sondern die explosion kann
ein auto zerstören oder kann ein
fahrerhaus von einem lkw zerstören aber
das was wir sehen das zerstört alles
außen rum daraus nicht drone sondern das
ist die munition die hier getroffen
produktion vielleicht auch kerosin
benzin dieser weise du hast die drohne
angesprochen wir wollen einmal weil
viele leute ja keine vorstellung haben
so sieht sie aus die drohne und eben
bewaffnet hier mit diesen
raketen die dann auf bodenziele
abgefeuert werden können du hast gesagt
türkische drohne wir sehen es auch hier
also aus türkische hersteller wie kommt
die in die hand der ukraine die ukraine
hat etwa vor zwei jahren den vertrag
abgeschlossen über die bayraktar die war
sozusagen der möchte die exportschlager
der türken auch der aserbaidschaner viel
davon gekauft und im krieg in armenien
die sehr erfolgreich eingesetzt
mittlerweile sind ungefähr 25 dieser
drohnen in der ukraine und ein weiterer
punkt der uns auch davor erschaudern
lässt wie unglaublich schlecht putin
diesen krieg geplant hat ist dass sie
überhaupt noch abheben könnten die
brauchen sie brauchen startplatz die
brauchen einen startbahnen landebahnen
die können nicht von irgend ein
waldstück abheben sondern wir brauchen
wirklich eine startbahn und die können
offenbar immer noch abheben das ist
genau das wonach richtig waren wollte am
ersten tag da standen wir haben darüber
gesprochen wie gezielt putin die luft
felder der ukraine bombardiert aber es
scheint ihnen eben nicht gelungen zu
sein alle dieser flug wälder aus zu
auszuschalten denn diese drohnen können
weiter starten sie starten aus
ukrainischen hoheitsgebiet die kommen
nicht aus der türkei oder sowas um das
einmal klar zu machen die ukraine habe
diese drohen gekauft und steuern sie
selbst aber der krieg der läuft nicht
nur in der luft sondern er läuft auch am
boden und dass dir das wollen wir ihnen
zeigen denn das zeigt wie mutig die
ukraine am boden wirklich kämpfen und
wie erfolgreich sie auch kämpfen wir
sehen jetzt hier gleich auf der linken
seite da sehen wir ihnen einen ich mag
ihn mal in gelb passend zur ukrainischen
farbe da steht er einen ukrainischen
soldaten vielleicht wenn wir das beet
einmal ins vorbild nehmen können wir
genauer erkennen und der der hat
geschultert eine anti panzer rakete und
dann julian erklären was passiert danach
ja genau also kann ich das tat er am
rand einer straße steht und mit einer
sogenannten ende einer britischen anti
panzer rakete schießt von denner hat die
ukraine etwa 1.000 2.000 stück gespendet
bekommen vor dem krieg in den letzten
wochen vor dem krieg und das andere soll
ich bin nicht ganz sicher aber soll ein
t90 aber sein dass einer der modernsten
kampfpanzer den den russland hat ja
direkt von der seite getroffen an der
seite ist die panzer und nicht so stark
wie wie vorne und insofern ist es
absichtlich natürlich das so sage 90
grad dort geschossen wollt könnt ihr
nochmal zeigen genau hier fährt der
panzer da ist er nach david kurz sehr
schnell nach da kommt der stift da ist
er noch intakter ferner durch dieses
dorf und er sieht wahrscheinlich nicht
dass hier von links eben die gleich
sozialen diese ukrainische rakete ihnen
treffen wird ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher wie wahrscheinlich sind noch
soldaten drinnen sieht der fährt gerade
nicht sondern die beiden stehen da am
straßenrand unter umständen wurden die
vorher gestoppt und das benzin
ausgegangen haben wir bei hunderten
russischen fahrzeugen erlebt den ist
einfach das benzin ausgegangen
irgendwann die soldaten verschanzen sich
dann da drinne wollen nicht rauskommen
und dementsprechend haben sie ein großes
problem der krieg du hast es von
eingangs schon gesagt ist blutig für
beide seiten lasst uns einmal schildern
wenn so eine rakete ein panzer trifft
und da drin sind noch soldaten was
passiert in diesem panzer was passiert
für die soldaten in diesem panzer ja ich
glaube da muss man nicht viel
spekulieren entweder die kommen
innerhalb von ein paar sekunden raus
oder sie werden entweder aufgrund der
schockwelle oder aufgrund des feuers
getötet jetzt schauen wir einmal auf den
gesamten wobei feuer bevor wir auf den
frontverlauf schauen wollen wir ihnen
noch einmal die situation am boden
zeigen und die heftigen verluste für
putin und das fiel am putins planung an
dem vormarsch der russen so überhaupt
nicht zu funktionieren scheint nimmt uns
mit in diese situation wir können sich
vielleicht noch mal voll bild zeigen und
julian du erklärst was wir da sehen und
was zuvor passiert ist vielleicht können
wir das genau einfach mal laufen lassen
um uns wirklich ein bild zu verschaffen
wie schlimm und wie katastrophal die
situation für die soldaten ist in die
ihr präsident sie gebracht hat was wir
sehen ist ein straßenzug nördlich von
kiew zehn kilometer nördlich von kiew
das ist die stadt butscher und durch
diese stadt man muss auch wieder sagen
und fassbar aus militärischer sicht ist
ein russischer konvoi gefahren stück ein
stück fahrzeug am fahrzeug hat sich
dadurch gearbeitet und offenbar nicht
darauf geachtet was links und rechts von
ihnen passiert die organischen soldaten
haben hier einen hinterhalt gesetzt und
zwar nicht einen kleinen hinterhalts
oder einen hinterhalt in dem sie bis zu
100 russische fahrzeuge zerstört haben
das ist also die gesamte speerspitze die
kiew angreifen sollte das was die
vorletzte statt butter danach kommt
ihnen auch da gab es gefälscht und dann
kommt hier und offenbar ist dieser
gesamte russische konvoi hier einfach
durchgefahren links und rechts sondern
die ukrainer mit ihren von der von den
nato-staaten gelieferten waffen
141 and low und ja berlin und hat dann
auch alles zerstört was dort zu sehen
war
strategisch vielleicht ein klassischer
hinter etwas gesagt wir kennen so was
aus dem irak aus syrien aus afghanistan
der konsul der rollt durch dieses dorf
man schreitet das erste fahrzeug aus man
schaltet vielleicht das letzte fahrzeug
aus und dann hast du viele schwere
fahrzeuge die nicht mehr vor und zurück
kommen und dann ist es eigentlich wie
auf dem jahrmarkt tontaubenschießen oder
zeiten scheibenschießen die kommt da
nicht mehr raus und ja die folge die
sehen wir hier auf der straße also ich
gesagt wir müssen ernsthaft bleiben hier
sind hunderte menschen gestorben
hunderte russische soldaten gestorben
die putin in den tod geschickt hat aber
von der sache her ist es so wie du es
beschrieben hast das ist ein massaker
was hier passiert ist an an russischen
soldaten und man kann nur hoffen dass in
russland auch irgendwie diese bilder
gesehen werden von russischen ehefrauen
von russischen müttern die ukraine
meldet bis heute morgen fast 5000
russischen soldaten ich glaube das sind
realistische zahlen 5000 menschen die
nicht nach russland zu hause nach hause
kehren werden nicht zu ihren eltern
nichts wie in familien absolut richtiger
hinweis julian abschließend die aktuelle
lage in der ukraine dass hier das war
tag 1 etwa die ersten kleinen donnerstag
ja genau die ersten kleinen
geländegewinne und dann haben wir mal
grafisch vorbereitet was ist seitdem
passiert was ist stand heute morgen
gestern abend passiert und wir sehen ja
vor allem sozusagen geländegewinne
verzeihung einmal noch mal zurück im
süden des landes und im norden des
landes also hier dazugekommen jeder zuge
kommen aber es ist eben nicht so dass
die hälfte der ukraine mittlerweile rot
gefärbt wäre wären die hälfte ist es
nicht aber man muss auch sagen wir sind
wirklich nur an tag 4 des krieges und
yahia wird heldenhaft verteidigt genauso
wie qi 4 im osten des landes und ja wir
haben hunderte höchstwahrscheinlich
mehrere tausend rosig das tote
aber wir müssen auch sagen dass die
ukraine gerade im süden in der region
herr werden
also möglich der krim auf jeden fall
extrem viel verloren hat hier ist die
großstadt milito pohl mit mit 160.000
einwohnern dort hat putin es geschafft
und das hat dass er 2014 geplant ein
korridor zu bauen ein korridor zwischen
der besetzten ausdruck rheine und der
krim dieser korridor ist jetzt offenbar
gelungen bis auf mario pohl ist die
letzte stadt hier noch dagegen hält und
das ist schon da um eben hier direkt ran
kommen zu können um hier eine land achse
zu haben truppen verschieben zu können
ist das strategisch wichtig das ist das
extrem wichtig und ist auch symbolisch
weil diese karte die wir jetzt hier
etwas sehen ungefähr die ist schon 2014
rom gegangen das war das so genannte nur
wurde cia das neue russland was also die
extremisten auch die im kreml gründen
wollten und das ist ihm nicht gelungen
sie wurden zurückgeschlagen interaktiv
und nur deshalb und so weiter überall
zurückgeschlagen nur in der ost ukraine
haben sie fuß gefasst jetzt und das muss
man auch sagen das könnte teil von putin
strategie seien hier aufgeht ist ihm
dieser dieser kuh gelungen sozusagen die
gesamten östlichen gebiete miteinander
zu vereinen aber ihm fehlen halt bis auf
milito polen und sumi ist umzingelt
fielen so gut wie alle organischen
großstädte bisher die auch haben will